welcome everyone the second session of
the morning this is on war landscape so
it's my pleasure to introduce our
speakers for the session our first
speaker is Austin Porter who's a post
doctoral fellow and visiting assistant
professor at Kenyon College where he
teaches courses on American art and
visual culture his research focuses on
the relationship between art and
politics and his work has been supported
by the American Council of learned
societies the loose foundation and the
Smithsonian American Art Museum please
join me in welcoming Austin thank you
very much and thanks especially to the
conference organizers the art gallery
the art department and everyone else
that made this possible this is really
pretty exciting for somebody that thinks
a lot about world war two and art all
the time all right in 1942 less than one
year after the United States entered
World War 2 Peter bloom painted a
disturbing work known as the raft this
image of three suffering skeletal men
adrift in a rubber raft is unique for
several reasons first though the scene
demonstrates an unsettling quality
similar to his earlier work bloom rarely
emphasized trauma like that seen here
relatedly blooms previous paintings
often recalled his own memories but the
raft drew on the experiences of US
servicemen stranded at sea the image is
also significant as bloom produced it
for the office of War Information or OWI
the primary us propaganda agency during
world war two though initially slated
for distribution as a poster the OWI
suppress the image and the raft has
since been suspended ideologically
between a work of modern art and war
propaganda and what follows I'd like to
resituate this painting within its
original wartime context while I'm
fascinated by its strangeness the raft
also raises questions concerning realism
and the representation of nautical
trauma during the international crisis
of World War two so first I'll briefly
discuss blooms rise in the 1930s before
return
to the war and this painting
specifically balloons career exploded
during the 1930s following the
exhibition of two strange paintings that
drew upon the artists memories the first
south of Scranton depicts a dreamlike
landscape based loosely on a drive bloom
took through eastern Pennsylvania in
1930 elements of the regional topography
including architectural details are
depicted with little concern for
accuracy in perspective or scale the
scenes most confounding element the
shirtless floating men on the right were
inspired by German sailors bloom
observed exercising on the deck of a
Harvard ship critics labeled the scenes
realistic an interpretation the artist
seemed to encourage according to bloom
while painting south of Scranton the
memories of his drive quote moved in my
mind from Scranton to Bethlehem to
Charleston things lost their logical
connections as they do in a dream in
quote the painting generated a decidedly
mixed reception one critic called it a
stunt canvas with no apparent artistic
value but in 1934 received the top prize
at the highly respected carnegie
international a designation that met
widespread criticism but contributed
significantly to the artist notoriety
blooms next major painting the Eternal
City was a caustic attack on Italian
fascism that quickly generated a heated
debate over the relationship between art
and politics painted after the artists
trip through Italy in the early 1930s
the canvas combined religious
iconography political violence and
government corruption within a chaotic
architectural space based on the roman
forum ruins while politicians accept
bribes in the foreground mounted
soldiers beat peasants in the distance
and frightened monks flee from the chaos
at the upper right the scowling
caricatured face of Benito Mussolini
Springs from a jack-in-the-box
overlooking the scene this pea-green
portrait mocked the plethora of Italian
propaganda featuring ill duche similar
to those bloom observed during his
travels thus bloom here subverted
Italian propaganda which linked fascism
to the glory of ancient Rome by
portraying a disordered state overseen
by a
toi first exhibited in New York in 1937
debates over the paintings political
content and utter strangeness continued
into the war years when the Museum of
Modern Art purchased the Eternal City in
1943 the art digest summarized the
controversy noting quote the hick sheeit
history of the picture has been
torturous it was exhibited in 37 in New
York and caused an uproar largely
unfavorable in temper and when presented
for inclusion in the Corcoran galleries
biannual of 1939 the hanging committee
refused to admit it end quote although
the Corcoran's director claimed the jury
declared the work political propaganda
unfit for an art exhibition the museum
likely sought to avoid controversy given
the city's foreign diplomats but oh how
times had changed by 1943 a statement
from moment declared the Eternal City
its most important American acquisition
to date heading into the war however
bloom was an unlikely candidate to
create government propaganda often
controversial and typically regarded as
strange his work arguably did not have
wide appeal perhaps most problematically
in the early 1940s bloom was associated
with magic realism this term popularized
by critics and curators such as momas
alfred bar referred to fantastic scenes
rendered in a representational style the
results scene and much of blooms work
included uncanny seemingly surrealistic
visions despite critical detractors
magic realism arguably gained popularity
during the war and its influence
appeared in mass culture and museum
exhibitions yet this manner of painting
seems ill suited for propaganda after
all the success of war propaganda
including posters is typically based on
content that quickly delivers an easily
understood message what then were the
details leading to the creation of the
raft an image equally strange as
balloons earlier work but injected with
unsettling traumatic content the process
began approximately six months after the
u.s. entered World War two when the OWI
requested poster designs from 37
well-known modern American painters
including rockwell kent then Sean and
Yasukuni oh she at the time OWI
officials such as Frances Brennan argued
world war two was an ideological fight
requiring conceptually driven modern
graphics Brennan promoted this aesthetic
previously while working as an art
director at Fortune magazine as seen in
this poster by the French designer Jean
corlew who which implores America to
open your eyes to the Gathering Storm of
Nazism while both images allude to
violence Britain was particularly driven
to avoid the more traditional form of
representation used in posters during
the First World War for example James of
Montgomery flags wake up America
distributed in 1917 holds a similar
message to Carlo's design on the right
but Flags allegorical rendering of the
USS Columbia who dozes what clouds
gather in the background is clearly tied
to late 19th century aesthetics and thus
lacked the more contemporary effect
Brennan sought and short Brennan argued
that World War 2 is a modern fight
requiring modern modes of persuasion and
that Flags poster was too old-fashioned
and to similar to advertising imagery
nevertheless this view was countered
sharply by other American propagandists
including the Treasury Department which
distributed posters featuring a style of
commercial realism that often embraced
an upbeat militaristic patriotism
examples include the work of NC Wyeth
whose 1942 war bonds poster featured
Uncle Sam unleashing hell upon the
nation's enemies are related to plural
is seen and more sentimental work
including Norman Rockwell's well-known
for freedom series including freedom
from want and this is of course one of
the four panels from paintings rather
from rockwell series that he initially
submitted to the OWI unsolicited which
they rejected later appeared in The
Saturday Evening Post became a sensation
and was later distributed in multiple
forms by the government and then
settling alternative strategy is seen in
the work of Ben Sean a social realist
painter whose owi posters depict and
depicts on an anonymous victim of the
German massacre at ledos a chicle
Slovakia known as this is not see
brutality Sean's design was based on an
actual atrocity widely reported in the
international press involving the Nazi
massacre of over 100 Chickasaw
Czechoslovakian civilians in 1942 thus
while Rockwell referenced
I deal Sean confronted the brutality of
the enemy directly Bloom's design
clearly Germans demonstrates a traumatic
affinity with Sean's work both artists
were sometimes characterized as magic
realists and both were included in
moments well known realists and magic
realists exhibition in 1943 and indeed
these works present formal details such
as exaggerated and distorted poses
unnerving color combinations and an
overall unsettling quality yet both
images are far more troubling because of
the violent historically specific events
that inspired their creation like Sean
bloom based his painting not on his own
experience but on a real-life tragedy
widely reported in the wartime press
before addressing that story I'd like to
discuss a significant missing element in
Bloom's design which is of course the
paintings lack of texts the words
crossing the victim in Sean's poster
denote a specific act of violence that
heightens its effectiveness how then
would any potential text in blooms the
raft motivate potential viewers and
function as propaganda since OWI
bureaucrats rejected blooms painting no
text was ever added to complete the
posters design however I have identified
a text intended for the unrealized
poster this phrase don't talk yourself
into it appears throughout OWI paperwork
connected to blooms painting by aligning
these suffering men with these words the
unrealized poster implores viewers to
abstain from spreading gossip that may
lead to nautical tragedy posters with
similar phrases including someone talked
and loose lips sink ships demonstrate
government fears concerning access spies
within the u.s. consider Frederick's
evils poster which portrays a figure
presumably a servicemen pointing
accusingly beyond the pictures frame the
implication of course is that we the
viewer have betrayed our duty to refrain
from spreading rumors surrounded by dark
and tumultuous waves this figures
suffering will end soon in comparison
the trio and blooms the raft appear
suspended in a strangely still moment
the surrounding water
almost supernaturally calm and these
contorted skeletal bodies though clearly
in pain suggests little movement in
other words seagulls drowning man on the
right will soon slip into a watery grave
while the trio and blooms raft will
continue suffering in this hellish
seascape by isolating these three
figures and pushing them to the
foreground bloom not only emphasised
their suffering but also alluded to art
historical precedence rooted in
religious martyrdom bloom was familiar
with similar themes in Renaissance art
including carlo crivelli stead Christ
supported by two angels from around 1500
during the 1930s this panel was owned by
the Met which is where blue likely first
saw it and he also owned a black and
white reproduction of this work note the
similarities between anguish faces
emaciated bodies and contorted bony
extremities comparable details also
appear in blooms earlier work including
Ella Mozena a drawing that featured
Christ surrounded by floating military
epaulets this study for a detail in the
Eternal City recalled the artist's
observation of Italian soldiers offering
military ephemera to a sculptural shrine
in San Marco while referencing religious
martyrdom blues painting was also
aligned with historical and mythological
scenes of nautical suffering from 19th
century romantic art take for example
dela caused the bark of Dante now at the
Louvre which depicts an intense moment
from the Divine Comedy here Virgil at
center attempts to calm Dante who
recoils at the anguished tortured souls
of the Damned surrounding their small
vessel of course blooms painted painting
is even more strongly linked to
Jericho's the raft of the Medusa
completed in 1819 Jericho's massive
canvas recalled a well-known tragedy
whereby 150 passengers of a friendship
were left to die at sea due to
government and competence both works
demonstrate a powerful synthesis of
classical themes of suffering and
contemporary politics however Jericho's
castaways have just noted a possible
sign of rescue on the horizon blooms
figures have no such hope their pain and
suffering remain suspended confined to
the small yellow raft while aligned with
earlier martyrs and
maritime tragedies blooms the raft also
demonstrated an affinity with numerous
contemporary representations of the wars
nautical front indeed wartime scenes of
oceanic tragedy became a regular part of
American visual culture that often mixed
fact and fiction for example in August
1943 Life magazine printed Tom lays
rendering of American servicemen going
over board the USS Hornet after a
Japanese attack based on lays sketches
made while traveling with the Hornet
these figures cling to a rubber raft and
a scene that evokes a modern Medusa
relatedly in 1944 20th Century Fox
released Alfred Hitchcock's lifeboat a
feature film originally scripted by John
Steinbeck set entirely on a small boat
the plot fold a ragtag group of
castaways sunk by a German sub other
references to nautical suffering termed
up and turned up in advertising comic
books newsreels news reports and
literary fiction in many cases symbolic
allusions to the ship of state were hard
to miss such symbolism was rooted in the
very real threat of the German and
Japanese Navy's servicemen and civilians
traveling across the Atlantic during
late 1942 and early 43 faced serious
danger specifically in October and
November of 1942 approximately when
bloom was creating his painting German
subs sank 235 allied military and
merchant ships more than any other
period of the war determining which
tales of nautical tragedy influenced
bloom is difficult though well versed in
literature and current events he rarely
painted seascapes however in the early
1940s bloom created a handful of strange
paintings based on an extended vacation
in Key West these works including Bowie
demonstrate visual similarities to the
raft and color nautical setting and
overall weirdness bloom later recalled
observing buoys on the beach and noted
how these objects used at navigation
markers often exhibited rough textured
surfaces that evoked an underlying
violence during his time at Key West
bloom also observed military servicemen
and may have seen naval training
involving life rafts off
Beach such as that depicted in this
photograph from the era while castaways
appeared throughout wartime visual
culture numerous details in the raft are
aligned with one specific and dramatic
survival story involving three US
servicemen the story began on January
sixteenth 1942 less than two months
after the attack on Pearl Harbor when a
small Navy aircraft crashed in the South
Pacific the pilot Harold Dixon a 42 year
old aviator miscalculated his
coordinates and landed into what he
assumed were unfriendly waters as the
bombers sank quickly Dixon and the two
young enlisted men in his crew Jean
aldric and Anthony pastilla managed to
secure only a few supplies during their
subsequent voyage they traveled more
than 1,000 miles in a small rubber rat
along the way these three men battled
sharks violent storms an unrelenting Sun
and emotional and physical trauma they
survived for 34 days by consuming
rainwater and small fish before reaching
an island in the South Pacific where
indigenous Islanders provided aid and
contacted us authorities severely
malnourished and near death the trio
eventually arrived at Pearl Harbor in
February 1942 this photograph taken
during the recovery shows each man
standing with the aid of a cane while
their raft rest behind them ensuing
media coverage celebrated Dixon and his
crew as patriotic heroes who exemplified
the can-do spirit necessary for American
victory abroad Life magazine published
an account of their survivors tale
written by dixon and illustrated with
photographs of the of the men after
their subsequent recovery rescue
recovery and ceremonial ceremonial
citations awarded by Admiral Chester
Nimitz this story gained an even wider
audience in the spring of nineteen
forty-two with the publication of a
novel titled the raft written by Robert
Trumbull Honolulu correspondent for the
New York Times the RAF told the tale
from Dixon's perspective an instant hit
the novel received rave reviews was
named a book of the month club selection
and contributed significantly to the
trio's heroic reputation politicians
praised the men as well including vice
president henry wallace who characters
characterization of their survival
appear
on the cover of the first edition quote
the story that generations of Americans
will be telling their children to
illustrate man's ability to master any
fate in quote Wallace's quote is one of
the many links between blooms painting
and this epic tale the vice president's
words were part of a well-known speech
distributed by the OWI to artists
enlisted to submit poster designs in
1942 the books first edition also
featured seven photographs including a
view of the three recovered sailors in
uniform and chatting with naval officers
while sitting in the raft they shared
this image also distributed widely in
the international press bears a striking
resemblance to the shape and perspective
of blooms raft other similarities
include a cylinder of carbon dioxide
used to inflate the raft that appears in
each image at the far left additionally
Dickson recalled how he recorded the
number of days spent at sea with a
series of hash marks made on the side of
the raft that appeared in photographs
featured in the book accordingly blooms
raft included a series of similar marks
as well as the starburst shaped design
on the vessels outer edge finally though
the men in blooms painting appear oddly
similar the artists demonstrated his
awareness of dixon in a pencil sketch
this untitled work dated 1942 shows a
strong similarity to Dixon's widely
distributed photograph and forgive me I
don't have an image of that but believe
me it's him it's definitely Dickson has
a very similar gaunt face government
records show that bloom submitted his
painting to the OWI in the fall of
nineteen forty two in order to be
transferred into a poster and
distributed widely however by November
the project was suppressed or to use
agency terminology killed at this time
OWI officials had begun moving away from
traumatic unsettling mg imagery seen in
the work of bloom and Ben Sean and
instead encouraging content similar to
rockwells more family-friendly fair the
decision to trade Shaun's social realism
and blooms magic realism for a more
comforting commercial realism was part
of a complex political process in short
the OWI slowly replaced
original staffers mostly new deal
loyalists on the political left such as
Sean with business friendly advertising
professionals who saw little reason to
display the wars violence after all
public opinion polls suggested Americans
had little appetite for visual reminders
of the horrors their loved ones faced
fighting abroad and instead favoured
posters with more pleasant imagery
though rejected for official use blooms
painted blooms painting demonstrated a
complicated negotiation between timeless
tragedies and a contemporary and
contemporary fears of a global war
against fascism the scene is
unquestionably intense these three
cadaverous bodies covered tightly by
intensely red singed skin suggests
anatomy's beginning to bear little
resemblance to human forms their gaunt
frames are juxtaposed jarringly against
the bright yellow raft which floats
strangely on top of and not within the
oceans unnaturally flat and calm bluish
green surface the final effect echoes a
critics description of an earlier work
by bloom quote it says morbidly
realistic as a whiff of a putra sent
corpse the OWI s decision to trade one
form of realism for another forced
modern artists such as bloom to seek
other options for supporting the war
less than two years after the owi dumped
the raft bloom completed fracture ward
commissioned by Abbott Laboratories a
chicago-based pharmaceutical corporation
fracture Ward depicts wounded soldiers
recovering stateside the canvas is
particularly memorable for the elaborate
system of traction equipment that frames
the patients on the far right though
both images deal with pain the figures
on the left are well cared for and
clearly mending specifically in a modern
hospital moreover unlike the raft
fracture Ward demonstrates blooms return
to drawing upon his own experiences in
fact while preparing for fracture ward
the artist observed servicemen
recovering at halloran General in Staten
Island the finished canvas was
reproduced in Abbott's promotional
publications and included in traveling
exhibitions that featured other war
themed paintings and as a side note I'll
just point out that the figure on the
right is involved in some sort of arts
and
crafts activity similar to the previous
discussion mentioned thus while blooms
OWI proposal was rejected corporate
sponsors proved willing collaborators
other artists faced a similar situation
and in fact Abbott Laboratories was one
of the most important private
co-sponsors of war art Abbott's most
important project was arguably Thomas
Hart Benton swell known series the year
of peril painted in 1942 Benton's
canvases including starry night are
filled with violence suffering and with
the art historic an art historian Erica
das has called pseudo surrealism
although intended for government
distribution officials labeled the
series too intense despite criticism
from government officials and art
critics that such unrestrained violence
was counterproductive to the war effort
Benton series was seen widely in
newsreels and in a lavish full-color
brochure sponsored by Abbott and that's
the cover of that brochure on the Left
determining why government officials
would accept one image and reject
another involves multiple factors in
closing it seems more important to note
simply that blooms scene of nautical
suffering was one example of many
created during the war and that this and
similar images projected an unsettling
strange visual experience that offered
viewers an alternative form of realism
than the photographic horrors of war
seen in newspapers magazines and
newsreels the appeal of a month more
unorthodox unpredictable system of magic
realism during this era is in many ways
not surprising after all wartime
anxieties touched countless domestic
economic and cultural standards as
millions of men enlisted and shipped out
overseas preconceived notions regarding
the rules of women and minorities in
public and private life were challenged
upset and reworked these resulting
shifts many of which were sudden and
extreme likely let it likely led many
Americans to see parallels between
wartime culture and the visual
instability of blooms grotesque realism
the suppression of blooms painting
reveals the politicized bureaucracy that
oversaw US government propaganda during
World
or two in fact blooms work was only one
of several proposals by well-known
modern artists rejected by officials who
sought to mitigate representations of
the wars harsh realities blooms attempt
to negotiate this political minefield by
combining classical imagery with
contemporary tales of nautical suffering
met an unfortunate end yet with the raft
bloom formed a scene with a powerful
cultural resonance that few other
paintings from the era suppressed or not
could claim thank you